U.S President Joe Biden has issued an
emergency declaration for parts of
California as intense rain continues to
drench the state evacuations have been
ordered for tens of thousands along the
California coast with flooding and
mudslides posing a risk to properties
and lives it's surprised us before and
it surprised us today it Rose very very
fast and when the alarm Bells went for
you know flood stage it was Rising about
two feet per hour and uh
here and we're fortunate that we are
elevated but we have neighbors in the
Grove who haven't been so lucky and it's
been really devastating
yeah I mean this is the biggest slide
that we've seen since we've been here
and and certainly on the lower end of
the neighborhood so we're on the high
end
um it's crazy to see the flood line you
know overhead
it's coming out of the creek over there
is overflowing the Creek and coming in
that Creek from out there is going over
the banks we worked hard
the last week to make sure this didn't
happen
and it was just
oh I've been here 28 years
and this is the most water we've seen in
28 years
it's it's really it's fun I don't know I
mean I thought at five o'clock we had it
licked I mean I really thought we had it
licked and it just
just came out of nowhere everywhere
how much time
Millions
Millions